mr. president you had a great line weeks
ago that you want to make sure that the
cure is not worse than the pandemic
itself and if you hear stories about
Shelly Luthor down in Texas who was
locked up thrown in prison for or in
jail for and find a lot of money people
came out of the Woodworks to support her
lots of money raised on on on her what
is it called when you go fund me go
exactly thank you and then Sean Hannity
last night interviewed her and said he's
going to give a donation to her and she
was full of emotion there and then
you've got this sheriff out in
California who's saying I'm not going to
arrest people or find people if they
don't if they open up their businesses
because he said I don't want to
criminalize people who are just trying
to work here's Shelly Luther if you if
you missed it on Hannity last night I
just woke up one day and I said I have
to open my stylists are calling me
they're not making their mortgage I was
at right now I still am not caught up
I'm two months behind on my mortgage and
my stylists were telling me that they
wanted to you know what do you think if
I go underground and go to people's
houses and I just said you know that's
not a good idea because we can't control
the environment there we we don't know
if it's been a disinfected or anything
like that and I just decided I would
open to create a safe place for the
stylist and to make sure that I wasn't
the reason they weren't making money
mr. president what would your reaction
when that judge threw her in jail for
seven days I said it was terrible I
thought he was a terrible judge the
governor agreed with me because the
governor and the Attorney General they
have a great Attorney General accent in
Texas but the governor was with me
yesterday Greg Abbott he's a fantastic
governor he was incensed he couldn't
believe it and she's an incredible
representative for a large group of
people that want to do the same thing
they want to get back to work
these people want to get back to work we
know they've everybody's done what they
have done and you can only do that so
long and that causes death also if you
look at all of the the problems that
people have with drugs and suicide and
they lose their jobs and anxiety and all
of the things that are caused by that
that's a big problem too you know people
don't realize that and I will tell you
you look at some cases some people think
they're doing it for politics here we go
again
but they think they're doing it because
it'll hurt me the longer it takes to it
hurt me in the election the longer it
takes to open up and I can see some of
that because some of these some of these
people are being unrealistic they're
being ridiculous I've looked at a couple
of states that are being absolutely
ridiculous but ultimately the people are
forcing it I see what's going on and
Gavin Newsom has been very generous to
me in a statement so I appreciate it but
you know I think they can move a little
quicker in California to be honest and I
think the people are forcing it the
people are gonna force it now not in all
cases in some cases you have to keep it
going longer but we've learned things in
the last two months we've learned a lot
about it and we may have fires and we're
going to put the fires out we may have I
say embers but we also may have some
fires and some reasonably big ones but
we'll put them out we've learned a lot
about this scourge this disease and but
you can't just we can't close our
country for two years you know I have I
had one doctor says well we could keep
it two or three years that would be
wonderful you wouldn't have a country
your country would break and we're gonna
have a fantastic next year
we will have a record or almost record
next year we're gonna have a transition
in the third quarter and it's happening
already you can see it and there's
spirit now there's a lot of spirit
because we have over 30 states that are
back or very strongly coming back and
that's going to be a lot higher soon
there's a transition that's taking place
so the third quarter is going to be a
transition fourth quarter I think is
going to be very good and I think next
year we're gonna have one of the best
years we've ever had if you don't have
somebody getting in and gumming up the
works and doubling and tripling your
taxes like sleepy Joe wants to do here's
no idea what he's doing